Traduttore: Samantha Sartini
Revisore: Federico Sangati
(Applausi)
Buongiorno a tutti, ebbene sì,
sono un criminologo,
non so se faccio più paura io a voi
o voi a me,
ma oggi non vi parlerò di sangue,
vi parlerò di città del futuro
e criminologia e sicurezza.
Sicuramente viviamo in città
che sono intelligenti,
o stanno diventando più intelligenti,
ma in città intelligenti noi
continuiamo ad avere paura
e la criminalità continua ad esserci
e le forze di polizia lavorano,
ma le risorse sono sempre più scarse.
Si può fare qualcosa di più?
Che cosa possiamo fare in queste
città intelligenti?
Ecco sono convinto, questa è l'idea
che oggi vi voglio trasferire,
che le città intelligenti hanno
degli anticorpi contro la criminalità.
La smart city ha degli anticorpi
o li deve sviluppare.
Come svilupparli è il tema
di cui vi voglio parlare.
Me ne occupo da alcuni anni,
me ne occupo nel mio gruppo di ricerca,
circa dal 2012/2013 e più di recente
me ne occupo in una start up
dell'Università di Trento
che abbiamo costruito,
dove facciamo ricerca sulla
sicurezza delle città;
ma facciamo un passo indietro
e cerchiamo insieme
di rispondere ad una domanda.
"La criminalità nelle città
si può prevedere?"
Sembra Minority Report,
ma vi assicuro che c'è della scienza
nella risposta a questa domanda,
se cerchiamo una risposta.
Parto da un aneddoto recente: Venezia,
qualcuno di voi forse l'avrà letto,
la notte tra il 15 e il 16,
qui sembro fare proprio il criminologo,
tra il 15 e il 16 novembre,
erano le 3 e 45 di notte, un criminale,
un ladro con la refurtiva scappa da
un albergo, c'è qualcuno che lo rincorre,
trova una volante ad acciuffarlo.
Quella volante era lì perché un software
aveva detto alla questura di Venezia
che tra le 3 e le 4 in quell'area
si sarebbe verificato un reato.
Non è Minority Report, questo software
si chiama “X Files”, scherzo,
“X Law” si chiama, se andate a vederlo,
battuta, si chiama “X Law”,
serietà adesso.
Quel software è un software
di polizia predittiva
che è stato realizzato dalla questura
di Napoli con l'Università Federico II
ed è in testa in alcune questure italiane,
ma non è un'idea del 2018.
È un'idea che nasce
negli Stati Uniti nel 2010
dove all'Università della California,
dei ricercatori hanno a lungo lavorato
con il dipartimento
di polizia di Los Angeles
e hanno costruito un software
che si chiama “PredPol”
che oggi è in ben 60 distretti
delle polizie americane negli Stati Uniti.
Vedete qui alle mie spalle
quei quadratini?
Sono predizioni nello spazio e nel tempo,
questi software
usano la criminalità passata,
i dati di criminalità passata,
per prevedere la concentrazione
nel futuro della criminalità
nello spazio e nel tempo.
Dove avverranno con buona probabilità
i reati nel futuro?
Stiamo parlando di reati urbani,
reati che hanno una dimensione, di solito,
patrimoniale, al massimo
di reati violenti urbani.
A Los Angeles
con l'utilizzo di questo software,
la criminalità di anno in anno,
dal 2018 ad oggi,
si è ridotta in alcuni anni
del 20% o del 30%.
L'obiettivo di “PredPol”, questo è
il nome del software, è cercare di capire
dove avverranno i reati.
Lo fa con algoritmi di predizione,
è un nome bruttissimo,
statistiche, matematica, quindi,
per andare a capire
dove avverranno i reati in futuro,
basandosi sul passato,
perché il passato insegna al futuro.
È la stessa cosa fa il software
della questura di Napoli,
della questura di Venezia,
con una piccola differenza,
lì si guarda la serialità del reato,
siccome spesso i reati
e i criminali sono seriali,
sono professionali, fanno più reati,
io riesco a prevedere
il prossimo reato di una serie,
sulle caratteristiche della serie stessa.
Quindi la criminalità può predire
la criminalità futura,
il dato di criminalità nella città
può farci imparare
dove avverrà la criminalità.
Ma è abbastanza?
Oggi le città sono più intelligenti
di un solo dato sulla criminalità,
oggi le città hanno i “Big data”,
se sono intelligenti,
quindi l'idea è
“come utilizzare questi Big data?”
A questo abbiamo cominciato
a lavorare nell'Università,
con un progetto
che abbiamo realizzato qui,
abbastanza unico, direi, al mondo,
dove forse di criminalità
non ce n’è tanta,
anche se non bisognerebbe dirlo,
perché i trentini non ne sono convinti.
Con la questura di Trento dal 2013 al 2015
e con l'Università,
noi come coordinatori,
con la fondazione Bruno Kessler,
e soprattutto,
ci tengo a sottolineare, il Comune,
perché questo è un elemento nuovo,
il Comune, le amministrazioni.
Due domande per capire l'idea
che vi voglio trasferire,
la prima è questa:
"Per prevedere la criminalità nelle città,
serve davvero solo il dato di polizia?"
Per capire che cosa succederà,
per capire dove andrà la criminalità,
serve solo questo dato?
Abbiamo solo questo dato?
E la seconda:
"Ma siamo sicuri che
costruire sicurezza nella città
vuol dire solo evitare reati futuri?
Vuol dire solo pattugliare
in modo più efficiente il territorio
da parte delle forze di polizia?"
Sicurezza vuol dire solo questo?
Sicurezza vuol dire anche sentirsi sicuri,
sicurezza vuol dire stare bene
e vivere la città.
E spesso vivere bene la città,
o non volerla vivere,
può essere non dipendente
dalla quantità oggettiva di criminalità.
Ma costruire sicurezza,
costruire sicurezza urbana
vuol dire lavorare anche su questi temi,
vuol dire lavorare con i cittadini,
vuol dire lavorare con le amministrazioni.
È questo che abbiamo fatto
e per farlo siamo andati ad immaginare
una città futura
che vuole prevenire la criminalità.
Quella città futura è una città fatta
di dati, è una città fatta di sensori,
è una città che ha sensori nel territorio,
che ha gangli,
che può prendere informazioni
e le può prendere
anche dai propri cittadini,
comunicando con i propri cittadini
in via costante.
Questa comunicazione porterà
ad ottenere tanti dati, di che tipo?
Dimentichiamoci per un attimo
i dati di polizia.
Alle mie spalle vedete
una carrellata di possibili dati
che oggi esistono in città
che non sono neanche tanto intelligenti,
perché esistono città più intelligenti
di questa che vi sto per mostrare
e che ci stiamo tratteggiando
in questo momento nella mente.
Dati sul traffico:
i dati sul traffico
parlano della vivibilità delle città,
ma parlano anche di dove andiamo
e dei posti che lasciamo sguarniti,
quindi hanno a che fare con sicurezza
e hanno a che fare con criminalità.
Dati meteo:
se piove di domenica io sto a casa
e se sto a casa è molto improbabile
che vengano a rubare mentre io ci sono.
Se invece non piove e vado via al mare
o al lago è probabile che si rubi.
Uno stupido esempio, scusate,
per farvi capire quanto
le condizioni climatiche
influenzano la criminalità e la sicurezza.
Uso dei trasporti pubblici:
una metro piena è un luogo dove avvengono
tantissimi borseggi, è un dato di fatto,
più siamo stretti come in un mercato,
più ci sono opportunità criminali,
ma una metro piena,
alle dieci di sera in centro città,
vuol dire che quella città
probabilmente è sicura,
perché il centro città è vissuto,
perché i cittadini stanno uscendo,
perché ci credono
e quindi vivono la città.
Quindi il dato della metropolitana piena
può essere in alcuni casi
anche un dato di sicurezza, di percezione
di sicurezza, dipende da come lo uso.
Dati nei parcheggi:
traffico, vi ricordate no?
Lo facciamo tutti:
entriamo in una città che non conosciamo,
andiamo nel parcheggio più vicino
con più posti a disposizione.
Quel dato il comune ce l'ha,
ma un parcheggio pieno all'aperto
è un parcheggio dove avvengono,
possono avvenire, con più probabilità,
furti di oggetti dalle auto, perché?
Perché il ladro si abbassa e si nasconde
tra le automobili ed entra nelle auto,
quando invece ci sono poche macchine
ci viene da dire: “chi ruberà?”,
è in quel momento
che non si ruba sulle auto.
Quindi il dato, quel dato,
è un dato che ci può servire.
Dati sulle utenze dei cittadini
di luce, gas e acqua:
vogliono semplicemente dire
quanto viviamo le nostre case
e se le lasciamo disabitate
o se ci sono interi quartieri,
e vi assicuro che si può vedere
solo con quel dato lì,
che sono spenti.
E se quei quartieri sono spenti,
sono disorganizzati,
sono quartieri dove c'è disagio sociale,
dove c'è disorganizzazione
e quindi dove c'è
probabilmente insicurezza.
Ecco che quel dato
mi sta parlando di un'altra cosa.
Dati di telefonia mobile:
ho qui il telefono,
ovviamente non ho
la geolocalizzazione accesa,
se l'avessi so dove sono, se ce l'abbiamo
tutti siamo in questo teatro.
Quando camminiamo quel dato
parla dei nostri movimenti
e sapete che il dato dei telefonini
è quello che predice meglio
- della concentrazione e quindi
delle persone che usano i telefonini -
la criminalità in città,
dopo la criminalità stessa.
Immaginatevi la forza di quel dato lì!
Se in un quartiere della città, in centro,
mentre tutti gli altri sono vissuti,
quel quartiere non ha telefonini accesi
è perché le persone probabilmente
potrebbero avere paura,
non stanno visitando quella parte
del centro, quindi quel dato lì
- che oggi le telefoniche vendono,
hanno minimizzato,
lasciamo da parte questa cosa -
è un dato importante che può essere usato.
E tutte le telecamere che mettiamo?
Sapete che le telecamere
oggi possono lanciare allarmi?
Contano quante persone passano,
quante macchine passano,
hanno algoritmi intelligenti
per identificare caratteristiche, fenomeni
e quelle caratteristiche identificate
possono finire in delle banche dati.
La telecamera digitale ha,
quindi, un potere informativo,
che va oltre all'uso che di solito
noi pensiamo possa avere.
E poi i dati di polizia locale:
le nostre multe,
l'amministrazione della polizia,
sto parlando della polizia municipale,
non le forze di polizia,
quel dato lì è un dato
sulla gestione del territorio.
Ci sono città intelligenti,
da noi Milano per esempio,
che hanno un sacco di informazioni
di polizia locale.
E i social media?
“Oggi mi hanno rubato in casa!”
“Oddio mi sento insicuro
in questa città terribile,
sono appena arrivato e non so dove andare,
sembra tutto buio!”.
Anche i dati sull’illuminazione
sono importanti
e ci sono nelle città intelligenti,
il dato del social è un dato di persone
che comunicano sicurezza oggettiva
o sicurezza soggettiva,
bisogna solo saperlo guardare.
E poi applicazioni
nelle mani dei cittadini.
Perché non fare un app in cui segnalare
- ce ne sono - reati,
segnalare insicurezza, segnalare paura,
segnalare disordine che ci dà fastidio?
E ricevere segnalazioni dalle nostre
comunicazioni sulla sicurezza
dalle nostre amministrazioni,
perché oggi queste tecnologie consentono
quella comunicazione
che non fa sentire solo il cittadino,
ma quei dati sono dati
che noi possiamo utilizzare.
E poi la collocazione
degli obiettivi sensibili:
una scuola, un bancomat,
un ufficio postale e così via,
o facilitatori,
case che sono rimaste incustodite
che possono diventare un luogo di spaccio,
luoghi di protezione,
come può essere una caserma,
questi influenzano la criminalità
rispetto a dove si trovano,
oppure la mancanza di criminalità
o le percezioni di sicurezza.
E poi tutti i dati
che tutti i comuni hanno:
purtroppo sempre meno open,
anche se dovrebbero essere open,
su informazioni sociali,
demografiche molto fini.
Vi ho fatto probabilmente una testa così,
ma pensate di avere tutti questi dati
a portata di mano,
di prenderli e di utilizzarli
per scopi diversi
da quelli per cui sono stati creati
e costruiti.
Lo scopo per noi oggi è
prevenire la criminalità
e far sentire le città più sicure
e i cittadini più sicuri.
Allora prendete, seguitemi
e immaginate di essere in una grande sala,
in inglese la chiamerebbero
- perché si usano questi termini no?
quando si fa criminologia -
“Security Control Room”:
una stanza di controllo sulla sicurezza,
da quella stanza io sono in connessione
con i miei poliziotti,
con i miei poliziotti municipali,
con i miei cittadini
e in quella stanza c'è un software
e quel software noi l'abbiamo già creato.
Non vi sto parlando di
una cosa lontanissima,
si chiama “Vigilium”,
l'abbiamo fatto con questa start up,
ma un software che gli assomiglia,
- non è importante -
un software che fa che cosa?
Che prende quei dati, che magari
li mescola con i dati della questura
e fa predizioni molto più accurate su dove
avverrà la concentrazione di criminalità
nello spazio e nel tempo.
E le fa più accurate perchè unirà
anche dati di carattere social,
di carattere sociale,
tutti i dati che vi ho fatto vedere
e quindi saranno più raffinate.
Queste previsioni a Trento,
anni fa le abbiamo fatte,
e funzionavano molto e meglio
della semplice polizia predittiva,
ma poi fa una cosa in più.
La risposta a quella seconda domanda
che vi ho posto, che ci siamo posti:
fa sicurezza urbana - questo è il nome
che gli abbiamo dato - predittiva,
fa sentire vicino ai cittadini,
fa capire il perché di disordine,
insicurezza, criminalità,
fa capire come intervenire,
perché oggi c'è molta pancia
nella gestione della sicurezza urbana,
e non solo nella gestione
della criminalità,
mentre serve un po’ più di testa,
un po’ più di raziocinio,
capire vuol dire intervenire e non solo.
Quando noi interveniamo,
immaginatevi un sindaco:
può mettere più illuminazioni,
può mettere le telecamere,
può fare più bella la città,
ha tantissime opzioni,
ma poi non sa
se queste opzioni funzionano.
Se quei dati continuano a monitorare,
noi sappiamo se gli interventi funzionano.
Questa è l'idea di una città intelligente
che ha anticorpi, che si protegge,
che è vicina ai cittadini
e di un'amministrazione che con i dati
- sempre tutelando la privacy, questo
non l'ho detto, ma è più che ovvio -
arriva a prevenire e a contrastare
e anche a combattere la criminalità,
facendo sentire la sicurezza
a tutti più vicina.
È un'idea che sembra lontana,
ma vi assicuro che è un'idea vicina,
con quella start up
la stiamo già costruendo
in una città molto grande italiana
e speriamo di poterlo fare presto
in tante altre città.
Vi ringrazio per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)
(Fine applausi)